there are about 1.5 billion cows on this
planet that's one cow for every five
people on Earth we keep them for dairy
and meat and they're a climate problem
that we've struggled to solve every year
each one of those cows is estimated to
release up to 220 lb of methane mostly
when they burp that's about 4% of all
greenhouse gas emissions that are
warming our planet from burping cows
you've probably heard a few solutions to
this like trying to convince people to
lower their beef intake or switch to
meet
Alternatives but instead of trying to
convince billions of humans to change
their diets some researchers are
focusing on the diet of the cows and a
promising solution might come in the
form of
seaweed this video is presented by Delta
Airlines one of the reasons cows produce
so much methane is because they're
specialized digestive tract it allows
them to digest tough plant material like
grass hay and other vegetation their
stomach consists of four compartments
the largest one the roomin acts sort of
as a storage unit where food can sit and
ferment microbes in this area break down
the food using a process called inic
fermentation this process provides the
animal with the nutrients and energy it
needs but it also produces methane as
waste and the cow burps it out which
makes the earth a little bit hotter
here's the thing though methane is
literally waste and changing the diet of
the cow can change how much of it is
produced foods like grass or hay stay in
the room in longer and produce more of
it whereas carbohydrate foods like corn
produce less methane but the goal here
isn't to completely change the diet of
all of these cows that we're feeding we
can just tweak it a
little we've been doing a h lot of work
on feet additives to try to reduce
anthetic methan emissions Aria Cabra is
the associate Dean at UC Davis in the
College of Agriculture and environmental
Sciences in 2018 he led a study that
tested how cows reacted to a certain
additive seaweed specifically red
seaweed which grows naturally in
tropical and subtropical ocean regions
back in 2016 researchers in Australia
had found that sprinkling the seaweed on
cow feed could potentially reduce
methane emissions by over 9
5% and in 2021 K and his team were able
to replicate the study in live animals
in California that completely blew my
mind when I when I saw how effective it
was the final results found that the
seaweed could reduce methane emissions
by
82% at first I couldn't believe it
because I I know I have never seen
anything like that before this specific
species of red seaweed contains high
amounts of a compound called bromoform
when a cow injust it it suppresses the
enzyme that makes methane and the cows
they don't even notice a change in their
dinners the seaweed is dried and
sprinkled onto the food they're used to
they can still get all the nutrients
they need produce milk and grow but the
waste is reduced other additives work
too like fatty acids which reduce
methane by lowering the carbohydrate
content and reducing a specific parasite
in the Rin known as protozoa and oregano
was found to reduce the number of
bacteria in the Rin to limit methane
production but so far out of all the
additives test seaweed has been the most
effective the best news is that scaling
up the growth of seaweed doesn't
technically drain other resources like
fresh water or fertilizer since we can
grow it in the ocean growing seaweed
could also combat other issues like
ocean acidification another climate
problem caused by Rising levels of
carbon dioxide but there's still a lot
of research left to do including
figuring out how to dry it and package
it and ship it at a low cost like how do
we effectively get seaweed from a
subtropical area to say main without
adding tons of emissions with shipping
that is if you didn't know seaweed is
super heavy when wet but once we figure
out the logistics it's over we solved it
the cows are content and the planet is
saved except not at all obviously for
one this doesn't appear to be a one-size
fits-all solution recently another
Australian study found that the same red
seaweed only cut methane emissions by
under 30% now granted that's still a
reduction which is good news but maybe
less of a miracle than we hoped others
are urging researchers to slow down on
red seaweed because of the broma form in
its pure form the EPA has reported that
it could be dangerous to human health if
ingested luckily studies so far haven't
found it at dangerous levels in milk or
in meat from cows eating the seaweed
additive but studies still need to be
done on how it might affect the cows
long term so it's not a silver bullet
but thankfully seaweeds is not our only
option I think this is just one of
several solutions that are being looked
at at the moment and overall there's a
big push for change in 2021 150
countries including the United States
signed the United Nations Global methane
pledge which aims to reduce methane
emissions by 30% by 2030 it's becoming
more and more clear now that we won't
get there unless we tackle antic methan
emissions in an Ideal World we have less
livestock but getting people to change
their habits isn't always the most
straightforward or quickest solution the
work of searching for solutions to The
Climate crisis needs to be multifaceted
within a year or two you will see quite
a lot of different activities different
solutions uh that that's going to come
up and that could be one less cow burp
at a
[Music]
time